la unión europea pues está por mantener
el contacto con los talibanes pero yo no
implica un reconocimiento oficial
asegurado el jefe de la diplomacia
europea
josep borrell los cancilleres europeos
reunidos hoy en eslovenia aseguran que
hay que mantener ciertos contactos sobre
todo para facilitar la ayuda humanitaria
o también la ayuda al desarrollo ahora
mismo congelada eso sí los talibanes
deberán comprometerse a cumplir ciertas
condiciones como el respeto los derechos
humanos también los derechos
fundamentales sobre todo los de las
mujeres también los de las personas más
vulnerables además apoyan la creación de
un gobierno inclusivo además de que
afganistán se vuelva a convertir en un
país que exporte al terrorismo además
los talibanes tendrán que comprometerse
a facilitar la evacuación de las
personas más vulnerables que deseen
abandonar el país y sobre todo también
de personas que trabajaron con países
europeos y que no pudieron ser evacuados
a tiempo por todo ello los países
europeos han acordado tener cierta
presencia en kabul cierta presencia
diplomática siempre y cuando la
seguridad de los trabajadores se puede
mantener para poder llevar a cabo estas
posibles evacuaciones además han
acordado la creación de una plataforma
de diálogo de un foro con los países
vecinos de afganistán para tratar
cuestiones clave como la cuestión de los
flujos migratorios o la lucha contra el
crimen organizado